as promised here on the rich eisen show
someone who i saw
back in the day on broadway when he was
in rent and he was fantastic in it
and he is the man through which uh or
through whom uh stella once got her
groove back
and uh also he is now in cw's
all-american
playing a football coach here in los
angeles that's just a few of the
highlights of the career of tay diggs
here on the rich isaac show how are you
tay
what's happening what's happening it's
uh it's good to be here and i'm hoping
you're well
i am doing very well let's get right
into your show uh cw's all-american you
play the role of billy baker
uh the based on the the story of spencer
pacinger who is in the uh the nfl
um yeah and and uh his is
an interesting path to the nfl um
going from crenshaw high to beverly
hills high here in los angeles to
to try and make it um how did you get
first introduced to this story
tay uh with that that part of the the
story is kind of boring it was just a
script that uh
okay that came across uh my desk
uh it was at the bottom of the pile just
because uh
i was not very familiar with with you
know the type of material that
the cw um dealt with uh
my assumption was that they just dealt
with like you know comic book stuff
and like uh you know kids shows sure um
but uh but i read it and i was
immediately moved and there are those
moments
in life where you feel like uh
you should kind of lean into the risk
um you know they weren't paying as much
as as i
was used to and and you know i wasn't
familiar with the network but the
the piece itself really spoke to me and
i felt like
this was something that i needed to to
uh
to take a chance on and i did and uh
and i'm i'm i'm very grateful you know
i'm really proud that
that that i'm on a show that it kind of
can deal with
with a lot of what we're we're going
through in life
uh currently as we're going through it
today uh i have 11 and i i have an 11
year old kid
and uh and we watch the show together
and we discuss
these these issues and it's it's uh i'm
i'm very i'm very grateful for those
moments so
i'm i'm having i'm having a good time
you sure are so
are you channeling any specific football
coach did you reach out to any actual
coaches to
get some ins and outs that you're you're
bringing to the to the screen right now
okay i'm surrounded i'm surrounded by
by uh by football players um
and um i kind of take uh i take a little
bit from from everybody i take from
coaches i take some
from teachers um you know i take a
little different players
um and then of course you know just uh
what i have been
in my own bag of tricks so uh thankfully
you know we're supported uh by uh by a
great
uh a kind of doubles team um and uh
the people that do our stunts are
incredible uh we're constantly running
routes
you know in between takes and okay at
least we were when we
we were one before the crazy but before
the crazy corona hit but uh sure so how
are you
how are you as a route runner tay then
let's get into that how are you as a
you know what if as long as my knee i
just turned 50 as long as i don't pull
the hammy
you know my hands are okay my hands are
all right uh i i can do it once
and then i sit down and let the
isn't it amazing tom brady's doing it at
age 43 tank he's playing in an nfc
championship game at age 43
crazy right it's crazy it's crazy yeah
i'm jealous yes uh uh it's very
impressive it's great i gotta tell you
that
i've always been um you know i i started
out
very athletic but then i i was too small
so i didn't do very well so i i
i started you know working with with uh
performing arts
but uh but i've always been a fan of
sports
and uh and being on the show has has
you know given me this ridiculous
respect for
for athletes you know professional and
otherwise it's
it's ridiculous what these people do and
what they continue to do
and uh and how they maintain so i'm i'm
uh
i might have a new newfound respect for
them tay diggs here on the rich eisen
show
so when you were at syracuse uh i'm
trying to figure because i'm
51. so when you were at syracuse was
like pearl washington there
was uh is this the ronnie cycling era
when you were in syracuse or the big
east
yep yep uh molten lawrence mountain
um derek eric derrick coleman
ac the great the great d.c yes
yes big dc that was that was his that
was his day okay so did you spend any
time in the old carrier dome at all or
or you just work i had a work-study job
uh
making pizza in the carrier dome wow
wow while the games are being played uh
i wasn't paying much attention okay
because i had to
you know go over my my ballet and my
singing
but uh but it was uh it was quite a
sight to behold
and uh and uh you know it was just a
great a great place to go to school
you know i had the the best of all the
world so i had a great
performing arts program but then you
know tons of just regular folks
as well so uh i feel very fortunate so
when you so
if anybody who remembers those great big
east heydays
and say hey i was in the carrier dome
watching these guys derek home and dc
and bayheim and do their thing
uh the pizza that they got from the
concession stand could have been made by
tate eggs it's basically
100 100 a good amount yeah
100 it was good too
it was good in those days uh i didn't
have to watch my weight so i could eat
it
okay and still had those ads so then at
some point tay diggs got his groove back
on that front is what you're saying
right pretty much on that front
okay i i didn't i didn't have it yet but
uh
but i was definitely working on the
groove it took me a minute what was it a
minute to get it i bet
it and then get it back again what was
it like to be on the set of that film
with angela bassett did you have any
sense because that was your first
that was your first film role you had
already hit it on broadway
but uh what was that like for you tay
diggs
it was a it was a combination because i
was very
once once i figured out what i wanted to
do
then uh the ambition kicked in so
um i was it was a combination of being
um you know grateful and in awe but then
realizing okay this is how the story
goes
and i need to follow the script you know
i mean this is what's happening so
i was uh i knew that that i was on the
right track
you know i mean um um it was it was
it was great and i i owe so much to to
answer the basset and the
you know the regina king was in that
movie and that's right um
they were really really you know just
supportive you know i mean i felt like i
belonged there
but they didn't know that i belonged
there and they treated me like i did
and uh and that that definitely uh
translated
uh so uh yeah it was it was it was a
it was like being in a storybook i'm
mandated ask was courtney b vance on the
on the set giving you the side eye but
next to the camera not decided not at
all he was um
he was uh actually giving me you know
he was there also just just even more
supportive
no kidding as a professional you know
giving me telling me
you know what to kind of look out for in
this business and to make sure i had
you know the right kind of
representation um everybody was just
so um uh just
gracious uh and generous with
with their experience you know i mean
from from what kind of luggage to get
you know angela beckett said i needed to
get to me luggage okay
good to know and then uh
and then whoopi goldberg said you know
always be be kind to your fans just keep
keep moving stay on the move those are
the things that
that i remember um it was awesome you
know we shot in jamaica
i mean it was it couldn't it couldn't it
couldn't have been a better
uh launch pad you know what i mean a
couple more things to ask
you tay diggs before i let you go on
with your day how did you wind up
how did you wind up voicing the uh fab
five documentary for
the 33 30 with the jaylen rose how did
you wind up in that uh
microphone i have no idea i just i just
said yes
okay i'm i'm very i'm slighty i'm
um i can be um uh
uh what's the word just i'm just not
always there kind of
uh aloof okay and uh and a lot of times
people will just
run things by me and i'll just say yes
uh and that was one of the things that i
just said yes
to had no idea um what i was doing until
i got into the studio
and uh and it was one of those jobs
where um
you know i truly was uh enjoying what i
was reading
and had to kind of remind myself that
that i wasn't just reading it for myself
you know that that uh that this you know
other people
because the uh the story was so you know
just so interesting
and um and you know in this industry
you run into these cats you know i mean
and i had um i had no idea you know
the the the intricacies of of that story
it was really great so um after that
i've been looking i haven't yet but i've
been looking for
for uh to do uh things you know along
those same lines
that was a that was a little gift a gift
of a gem right there
never know uh before i let you go again
you're you're speaking of reading your
children's book um my friend i'll give
you the floor on that oh man yeah
i've been lucky enough to to have uh
written a series a series of books first
one it's called
chocolate me second one mix me uh the
third one's called i love you more than
and now i got uh
my friend out that's uh it's about
the friendship and how uh friends have
to kind of look out for each other and
when one falters
you know to kind of uh uh stand up
and have your friends back and make sure
you remind
you know your people where they come
from and and that they should uh
should act right so uh we're we're
taking the
two characters from from chocolate me
and mixed me
and uh combining them and delving into
their friendship so
it's the same illustrator uh as all the
other books shane evans
we uh we met in high school and we
continue to be great friends
and uh and writing partners and uh and
i'm you know
excited to to put this book out and
hoping they do as well as the as the
others
fantastic today uh last question we
noticed uh when we were preparing some
photograph still photographs for this
interview that you have an absurd amount
of hats how many hats do you have
t digs how many houses oh 48
000 and i have no idea oh you should
have given me the rent number you should
have give me the rent number
525 600.5 plus
that's why you don't setting
thanks for the call uh the cw's
all-american eight eastern
on monday episodes the next day for free
only on the cw's how you can stream them
the next day season three of all
american with tay diggs thanks for the
call
thanks for having me man take care you
bet that's tay diggs right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here